ladies and gentlemen here is the dynamic
young actor who starred in the film's
looking for mr. Goodbar an American
gigolo and is currently appearing in hit
Broadway play bent Richard Gere
I'll say one of my friends on my bench
in New York I'll see you tomorrow night
it's my great pleasure to be here
tonight to present an award the Academy
Award of Merit for the movie Ola you
know these are the two machines right
here reven the old one which is mark
just told me that it was from the 30s
sometime mid thirties and the other one
is a very recent model
these machines are tools that are used
in the editing process basically I've
done the new one you see that the spool
on the left is where the the sound goes
the sound of the spool on the right
where the exposed film goes he
synchronized it up very easily because
of this machine and an editor can use it
as a tool to assemble the footage I
think it'd be safe to say that that more
film has been seen on a movie Ola than
on all these screens and all the movie
houses in the world put together so I
think it's only fitting that we award
the inventor of the movie Ola
in fact his son here Michael Surya marks
are you I'm sorry for the invention of
the media
marks
Oh sir this is an award for technical
and very special achievement award for
the invention of the movie older thank
you very much
governors of the Academy for this
beautiful symbol which recognizes the
role my father played and later I played
in the development of the movie Ola I
think